a real estate is maybe the last product
that we consume
that would have been manufactured in our
city
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders today i am
joined by eran the ceo and
co-founder of hop investments
iran pollock oversees a diverse
portfolio of residential and commercial
real estate that is renowned for its
location proximity to mass transit and
innovative construction and design
mr podak is an established entrepreneur
with a long history of successful real
estate ventures in eastern europe israel
and the united states mr pollock's
strengths are the early identification
of emerging regions and the development
of projects tailored for those markets
he is one of the first developers to
identify east harlem as well as the
journal square neighborhood of jersey
city as areas in preliminary stages of
urban revitalization
he was also an early leader in the
revival of new vetsele a highly coveted
neighborhood in the heart of tel aviv
[Music]
you're a veteran for the area
and veteran in the real estate industry
you're
responsible for some incredible projects
um and and even more than the actual
projects which i encourage anybody to go
to to the website of your organization
to look at it it's the way that you
think through these projects and the
strategy and the
the the well-roundedness
that you understand of
the consequences of your actions and how
how the the environment also impacts the
success of the projects and at the end
what the consumers want i think that's
really interesting and so iran thank you
very much for being here tell me a
little bit about yourself and
what real estate is for you why you're
dedicating
sort of your career to real estate
yes so
i'm going to turn 50 next year
and i'm 30 years in a business
did a lot of stuff
all of those years i was doing real
estate i'm doing real estate
since the day that i finished my army
service in israel started very small and
bought one apartment renovated
and a good to
be a real estate developer
got into construction it was a
construction company now that is doing
construction for us and for others
and
i love real estate i think it's uh
we all using it um
it's uh the main product that all of us
is using and uh in a
you know a lot of everything real estate
is everything people getting married
people getting engaged people having the
children people
getting out of the parents house moving
to their own house
and
you know and in some cultures people
stay together and and go in the houses
we know that the
former the culture in the in the north
of israel for example
um
so it's a very interesting culture a
cosmopolitan
industry
and
i i love it i really love it
and so
you know obviously real estate is is a
cornerstone
of the american dream as well right i
mean it goes back to this idea of
working hard so that we can own
keys to our own place and we can live
a we can live a comfortable stable life
with four walls and a roof above our
head that will keep us safe and secure
that is what the home is for us what the
cave was for the
for frino for our ancestors and so
transitioning though to this idea of
project management and building these
large-scale projects these huge
buildings
as part of your work
you know why why choose that route in
real estate
why choose the art of
doing more bigger projects then
well i think it's uh it's a new york
thing
when i started in new york i did started
there with smaller projects
and i found out that
in new york it's a very complicated
city
a very hard city to build in and
economy of scale is a is uh
is important here
and what i learned
uh i think is that and what i learned or
what i'm seeing in the last i would say
three four five years and now even more
is that there is much bigger demand for
a partner either as rent or
a as condo to buy there is much bigger
demand for apartments that are in a big
buildings
well
with 12 amenities with all the amenities
swimming pool rooftop gym
sauna whatever you can have
and there is much more demand to those
big projects
that give you more and more services
and
we are also getting more and more and
more into crea community creation yes
yeah driving and advisors i mean having
some person that is a pivot in the
building
and
trying to get engagement
and that's like the reason that i'm i'm
learning and seeing during my 30 years
career that it's it's it's better to
focus it's more it's the right and the
other thing is
uh that i think is very interesting and
that's that's quite real estate all over
the world not just in new york
a lot of our time now talking about
which i love
learning about what people need you're
talking about building these community
projects you're talking about concierge
advisors communal living different
things that aren't trivial right i mean
we can we could have conceived of these
ideas perhaps 20 30 years ago but really
through societal changes we're seeing
how what people want and what people
need and you sort of as a visionary and
and as the owner of these projects you
are laying the foundation of of what do
we actually implement now versus versus
later and and how do you make decisions
and so i'm really curious about that
how what process do you go through to
determine
what is the right sort of methodology to
work through these projects and what do
people actually want
out of their living space in the
buildings that you're building
so i think it's about uh using the space
as good as you can and as efficient as
you can
so first of all
we live in a world now that the
apartment that have been built are small
they're smaller it's a fact
um
a one bedroom will be 600 square foot
even 550 sometimes a two bedroom will be
700 square foot 800 maybe thousand
square foot
and
what i think is people
i think the consumer is
okay with that
with the
having we put living in a smaller
apartment
but if you can give them the amenities
that are shared between 100 200 300
apartments 400 apartments
so
then they have another space that they
can use
for the free time or for having guests
or parties or
wall or study
so i think uh a space to walk and study
is important a space to have friends and
to have a glass of wine with them uh
that is outside of your apartment
um
but iran is uncommon for everybody so do
you think at this point that every
project needs to have these spaces or or
does it depend on the demographic
that perhaps is supposed to live there
so i'm very much focusing on new york
now and i'm i'm here and that's you know
in new york from what i see
there is
that there is huge demand for that
and the difference between
a building like that or building without
of all of those amenities can be
30 20 30 40 and even 50 in prices
people are willing to pay for that
i'm seeing those buildings being rented
much faster
if a building without amenities you you
will open and it might may take three
four five months to rent everything for
six months a building with a manatees
and can take a month
wow okay and so
if you're now
zooming out again a little bit about
this video of projects give me a little
bit of insight as to what's happening
with your group and what you've done
over the last 30 years and just in terms
of you know
scaling some numbers
just so that i have a some some bigger
picture
yeah i was working in eastern europe in
budapest
uh
working on a smaller scale
but i i i did project that i really
liked over the six eight apartments very
boutique
um it very it was fun was very
interesting and very successful
and then i did two projects over there
that were already bigger with hundred
apartment each
and then i was walking in israel like a
few years
and
doing almost everything in real estate
from you know just buying an apartment
and renovating to building projects
and trading in real estate everything
will stay and when i started here in new
york at 12
maybe already 13 years ago
i
started again smaller
six apartment eight apartment 20
apartment
uh buildings apartment buildings and go
to a bigger project right now i finished
a large project in 28th street
and we took an apartment i'm working
project in jazz city with 900 apartments
wow you know i'm still looking and
looking for i have a very interesting
project in tribeca that i like a lot
it's a great neighborhood and the
concept is going to be very nice and
again we're going to combine between
nice amenities
to a great brand um we're going we're
going to call it the rebels which would
be like
you know for people that did something
in their life and have already like you
know money and uh the 40s 50s but they
still want to consider themselves but
it's like crap but by the way over there
we're going to try a new thing and we're
going to have a musical
and we're going to have a room that
would be with all the acoustics and the
drums
and um
the thing for the guitar the amplifiers
for the guitars so we're taking we're
doing a luxury very heavily luxury video
and but we're doing the manatees that
are like all kinds like whoever you know
and so on when you're mentioning these
different projects and tribeca and new
york et cetera but
how how do you just i mean it sounds
like these projects you know they're
they take a long time right i mean and
and once you commit
you you know you're committing to
something that's that's long term often
times do you yourself
research and come up with proposals or
do people come to you with requests and
proposals how do you even
start to think about you know even where
you want to do a project
yeah i think it's a it's a it's an
amazing question and because
like you said it's a it's a song like
2018 for example it was a seven-year
project it was an assemblage a few few
different pieces of land
until we bought everything until we got
everything approved
and you're right you're planning
something for the future in a way you're
planning something that's going to be on
the market that three four five six
years from now
and
what i'm doing and what a lot of
developers are doing is like first of
all you
basing a lot of decision on data you
will go
on the internet on all of the databases
collect all the information about
buildings in the area
schools are very important which school
what schools
uh for example in 28th street there is a
very close by like one of the newest
most important uh private schools in new
york and that school was a lot of
consideration for us and we're seeing
now that we are selling to families
that goes to that
and so data and then there is the people
right bringing walkers
and we listen it they tell us we think
people would need like one one bedrooms
two bedrooms three bedrooms three
bedroom should be xyz square foot people
we want that amenities all these
amenities
and then
also i have my stomach meaning
sometimes i'm looking at the data
hearing uh everyone around me
hearing the themes but sometimes like
28th street is a good example because
when i when i bought 28th street
some people were arguing with me that
it's not even chats
and don't you know don't make effort
don't make it too fancy don't invest too
much try to be very moderate
now a year ago two years ago facebook is
buying offices at 34th street and they
are saying this is our office in chelsea
so 28th city is already in the center of
chipotle
wow
[Music]
and this obviously happened
this happened long after you committed
to the project
after that i'm into construction
so
but you need to see those things
happening because they would happen
because cities especially cities like
new york have the nature to go
neighborhoods in cities like new york
have the nature to grow
and to expand
so you need to see all of thing what
will happen what is now what people
would like
um
i think and it's an a and a it's a
different topic maybe that one of the
challenges of real estate and real
estate development these days is tech
because you you're starting a project
and you want to adopt tech into the
building right you want to have things
you want to have like
smart homes or all kinds of interesting
texts
but saying i'm gonna finish the project
in three years four years
and tech is always changing and this is
i think one of the most interesting
challenges that real estate developers
are facing now making decision on the
tech that you will invest and put into
the buildings
right
so and we're looking at also a lot of
companies that are not just looking at
tech
in the buildings but also tech to build
right i mean the whole way the
construction is being done
is also changing is that impacting a lot
do you think the way that
that project managers like yourself or
you know entrepreneurs like yourself
you're thinking through you know costs
and integration with tech and how the
real estate world will look like in the
future
yeah
yeah i
so i think there is a
if you look at the real estate industry
i think the first uh thing was a
project management software where there
are few now that are very good very
successful
and we're really enjoying using them
really feeling it's improving the
processes
and i think like at least for us
uh
this
those
programs were
well implemented into our organization
it is what that's it it's working smooth
now we're looking more into a lot of
other things like a lot of
softwares that are helping you
for example estimate the cost of a
project
um estimate um
quantities in a project how much
concrete or how much units of the air
condition and things like that
and
this i think this segment of the market
is not cooked yet hundred percent there
is a lot to be done a lot to be
researched
um a lot uh
a lot
there are a lot of uh interesting things
and i'm seeing a lot of interesting
things
there is a company that developing a new
concrete now
and that is the big promise there was
our 50 million dollar was invested
within them already but the amount of
the concrete that our manufacturer until
today was done
and it's a much better concrete
obviously much cheaper and most
importantly it's better for the
ecosystem much better for the ecosystem
it's more great but it will take them
time to get to real production that you
can
build the whole building with that
tell me about community
um
you know the surrounding community the
surrounding
uh businesses and and and how that plays
a role with with the project that you do
because you one of the things we talked
about right before we started was the
fact that you're not just involved
necessarily with the actual building
itself but you actually are thinking
strategically about the surrounding of
the building and how to create a win-win
situation that that helps everybody
emerge so so what what do you do there
for example yeah i think that
i think the biggest concern in uh
in the real estate industry in the big
cities
is our retailers and we're seeing them
all closing
they were starting to suffer before
probably
from the trend of online buying uh and
kovid is
really it was really like was killing
the retail industry in
especially in city like new york and i
think
for us
retail is important first of all it's
part of our business model uh
we're supposed to make money and a lot
of money on that segment of the building
on that part of the building and that i
think real estate the retail is
important to all of us as a community
it's boring to go in the street that
there is nothing that all the retailers
as close it's
giving us a more
a dangerous feeling or more like an
abandoned feeling and it's much nicer to
go and that you have nice interesting
stores or you can have your
local retailer and what we took what we
were trying to do in the
in our portfolio in northern manhattan
was to try to push our tenants to buy at
local retailers by giving them a
discount on the buys strong meaning
10 percent of what they are buying in
the retailers in the neighborhood we
would give them as a discount in the
retail and do that we did that for a
certain time
it was uh it was okay it was
it was not a big success but it was it
showed me at least
that there are things to do and
to consider in the future and i i think
we all need to find a way to support
our retailers
and
so we will have nice
more vibe neighborhoods more happening
neighborhoods
is i lost you in the last sentence
can you repeat that
i said that we all need to think about
our retailers
and to support help make them you know
so because it's it's nice to have a
neighborhood with nice sweeter with
vibes with people in the street with uh
that everything is happening
yeah i think i think the interesting you
know insight from here is this idea that
you know you're not just building a
building you're building a life right
and you're mentioning that at the end
this the the way you're looking at real
estate it's one of those last things
that are getting manufactured in our
cities it's it's for for the vast
majority of people around the world it's
sort of the holy grail of getting of
getting to sort of their their stable
state and and a huge part of it is the
community and we've seen over the last
few years how community has been
playing a bigger and bigger role uh
things like retail and vibe etc and so i
think that's that's really really
interesting and uh 20 minutes is not
nearly enough to uncover
you know anything it really about about
the space in a deep way but but i did
learn from here
a lot of you know the the mentality that
you bring into this both the long-term
thinking
on the investment side on the commitment
side thinking about community thinking
at the end about what what people
actually want and over 30 years keeping
an open mind about how to pivot and how
to continuously improve
and i definitely want to check out the
music room in the new rebel building
yeah
it will take another two years but we're
going to play something together over
there i don't know today but i can you
know
i'm excited for that i can make some
noise
i love that
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you this is great
[Music]